con banderas sudanesas decenas de miles
salieron a las calles de jartúm cerca a
algunos manifestantes levantaban
barricadas con piedras y neumáticos
quemados todos exigen la salida
inmediata del general al burhan líder
del golpe de estado
estamos en la calle para echar atrás el
régimen militar de sudán que se mantiene
por 53 años hemos sido testigos de la
opresión y represión por parte del
ejército esperamos que sea el último día
de régimen militar en sudán
ante las concentraciones la onu y eeuu
habían advertido repetidamente contra el
uso de violencia esto tras la muerte de
más de diez manifestantes desde el
inicio de la semana llamados a la calma
que no impidieron la muerte de más
ciudadanos este sábado
los manifestantes piden la salida de los
militares del poder después de 2019 y el
fin del régimen de omar al bashir inició
un periodo de transición con una
división del poder entre civiles y
militares el golpe de estado del general
al burhan apartó a la parte civil del
poder comenzando con el primer ministro
abdalá hamd ok arrestado en su
residencia el golpe ha puesto fin a la
esperanza de elecciones libres para 2023
y ha profundizado aún más en la crisis
del país esta semana de eeuu y el banco
mundial suspendieron su ayuda financiera
a jartúm